We've all missed someone so much that we start to romanticize the past
It throws off your judgement and soon you're overwhelmed with just wanting to be with that person again
While people often say that absence makes the heart grow fonder, it instead allows feelings of being miserable and empty to grow instead
Before deciding to get back together with your ex, watch this video for reasons about why you shouldn't
After you've been separated from someone, There's a tendency to romanticize the past
Meaning that you focus only on the good things that happened and ignore all the bad
By blocking out all the reasons why you two didn't work out
You're recreating a false image of that person
You're remembering somebody who didn't really exist
When you remember only the good you no longer miss your ex and instead miss the idea of them
For example say you just broke up with "Person A." You start to miss them and think of all the good times you had together
Ignoring all the times you and "Person A" fought or argued
You focus so much on all the good things about person a that. You've created a whole new person. "Person B"
You don't really miss Person A because you miss Person B, who sadly is only an idea
Instead of blocking out the bad things that happened focus on them
So you can learn. Learn what personality traits you want to look for and what traits you want to stay away from.
Let yourself grow and move on
Breaking up is a drastic change and no one likes change. It's natural to crave familiarity
So we often go back to whatever. We just lost whether it was healthy or not
You aren't used to being alone or dealing with the loud thoughts in your head
You're used to having Person A to talk to, so not having them around is frustrating and leaves you with a sense of emptiness.
It was comforting having PersonA around to talk to. Why would you want to keep them away?
However, while familiarity is comforting, you must remember that familiarity isn't always the healthiest choice.
Sometimes, you need to step out of your comfort zone to be happy
coupled with familiarity
After our breakup you end up yearning for closeness
Being close with someone is a special feeling one that often leaves you feeling empty once gone
You miss knowing the other person inside and out, and them knowing you as well. However,
Remember that being close to someone isn't restricted to that specific person and being close in general doesn't necessarily create happiness
Instead of focusing on the crave for companionship focus on yourself, and how you can be happy being on your own
You both have changed since you first started going out
your experiences together have shaped who you've become and you are no longer the same people you once were as
You grew as people you also grew apart. You could no longer change together, so you had to make the ultimate change and breakup
Change is never fun and it can be tempting to avoid it altogether but stopping yourself from growing is not the solution
You should continue to help yourself grow in that process you will find people who can grow alongside you
After pouring all your love energy and hard work into a person it can feel like they owe you love
But beating a dead horse won't do you any good
You can never force somebody to love you. No matter how much you try
Human nature has us naturally rebel against force as we don't like being told to do things
This especially applies to love in relationships forcing someone to love you doesn't make them
love you. In the end, they may resent you, creating a larger gap between you than there was before
Don't try to force love and you'll end up being happier
Compatibility is key in a relationship, and when it's gone. There is little hope for success when revealing yourself in a new relationship
this is when compatibility is tested and often fails as
You learn more about each other your true colors shine and you discover whether it's meant to last or not
After a breakup as more time progresses
It'll be easier to look back and see how you two were incompatible and are much better being separated
It can be hard to see it in a heat of the moment
But remember that it'll pass ,and you'll be happier being on your own
Well it may seem hard to see someone else will come along and be a much better match for you
You will have learned from your mistakes from your ex so you know what to look for in your new partner
And you will be able to spot warning signs before they get out of hand.
You will have grown as a person from your last relationship
Able to handle different things. You will be able to lead a new life and a new relationship staying on safe and healthy waters.
Don't give up on love. It's out there, and you'll find it when you're ready
Remember that it's healthier to let go than to hold on to a love that isn't there anymore. That's all from us.
It's Psych2Go. What do you think of these reasons? Be sure to subscribe for more tips on living a healthy life!